all right
Morocco yes were you from Persia dro I
grew up in Las Vegas
nobody childhood you grew up with both
your parents my mom I give him the mom
in my my stepdad you raised me my
biological dad was in prison for most of
my life yeah he was some the motorcycle
cat you know we're just club yeah got
busted for son Chris crystal method
methamphetamines and um he went away
yeah the most my life he was gone my
stepdad the Rays music it was a just a
sustained I feel really really really
blessed to have him there's a dead how
was your childhood otherwise any of you
said increases yeah honest yeah there's
own surprise I'm talking about but there
was a really nasty demented just [ __ ]
twisted neighbor you um and you probably
gathered but you like those sexual just
abuse and discussing this that I'm round
like for to like seven mmm yeah
Navin other than that I mean I feel like
I'd it had a good childhood um generally
happy kid like yeah I mean I feel I felt
blessed growing up still
I mean a little fat and yeah I'm not so
fat now I guess so you left home at what
age
oh when I was 17 yeah I got it
what's that I moved into a apartment
with my girlfriend cuz I'm I mean just
stop I want to get the house as soon as
possible like do my own thing I started
working for the department
transportation issues what my mom was
doing at the time and yeah I did that
work in the Sun shop there um I actually
ran into when you were first working
there um you're on probation and I ran
into the like the head department
transportation guys car with with asti
vehicle and so it's fired like a video
but it was a good job you know the first
couple months I was there then you came
down his Father's Day 2006 I got hired
to play bass for this girl he was signed
to Virgin UK records and I just job
everything came out you know we're
stoked I'm bagging putting music for
freaking ever and it the opportunity to
come to LA for Vegas is I'm not gonna
pass it up you know so I dropped
everything came out and been here ever
since
so now you're leaving we're on Skid Row
not in the row but I live in a hatch
it's um it's like but most people don't
know but in LA enough but the rest of
the country but you know they come the
freeways the underpasses we're like you
can I just I didn't underpass oh the
bridge is that if you walk up alongside
there today to the belly of the bridge
there's like little hatches inside there
and if you go there's one over on I'll
tell you exactly where over on Figueroa
in Temple I stay in one of those hatches
it's for under the bridge right there
and you jump up inside there I don't
know what it's used for you like I don't
have a clue it's like the size of I
don't even know how to describe it like
maybe 40 by like 20 feet it's huge it's
huge it's maybe like five 10 at all
right and a bunch of us are there the
whole mess was Maja's yeah that's not
bad I mean it's better than being to me
I it's better than me in our tent it
feels very less exposed but that
California Highway Patrol goes by and
messes with us and has do a little weird
sobriety testings for them just random
but I mean yeah I I kind of like you
know here for a minute on the streets
that fella can upgrade
honestly that's yes it's probably safer
right yeah I feel same for sure
absolutely absolutely for Sevilla and so
what is your drug now um Hamlin healing
crystal when did that start when he does
it yeah
heroin specifically well
drugs in general drugs I guess I was
like 14 I yeah I mean like the gradual
progression is like you feel like most
cats do like weed
then there's mushrooms coke man pills
honestly when I found painkillers that
was like putting on new skin for me dude
I felt like I'm comfortable for the
first time ever you know I don't know
why I just always felt uncomfortable in
my skin and painkillers for me for some
reason the second I took a dude the
second I first frickin pillars like
that's that's what I need that's the jam
it like that makes me feel okay no now
my goal in life is just to stay high
basically and I know that'sthat's
depressing and thinking of that but I
mean that's my question so honestly yeah
that was my that some reason opiates to
me anything right and how does heroin
compare to pills uh-huh terribly
honestly on my opinion when the best
cousin ever had was oxycontin and I give
you a good like warm like confident
feeling but also gives you energy um and
for me I ox got almost it was a tip so
you didn't use the only pill I want to
say I was only enjoying warranty but
they stopped making those things and
they got a really expensive and so the
natural progression honestly when I went
to my first we have they told me the
heroin is like that's so much cheaper
buh-buh-buh and I never ever ever ever
ever wanted to take do heroin like like
when watching movies stuff like that and
be honestly I didn't read my it but like
the thought of sticking you know my arm
still today is disgusting as hell to me
dude and it blows my mind that I'm even
better even do it dude
but being dope sick is terrible it's I
mean you feel like you're dying you want
to see feel like you're dying and so I
mean instead of feeling like dying
instead of dying
it's like fight or flight I'm gonna
gonna die or I'm gonna like get well and
you know I've chosen you know I mean a
few times I've chosen to rather die and
get sober and I've really enjoyed those
times but yeah that's yeah I'm gonna
make sure remember the exact question
but you
before yeah the most time patters of 17
months how'd you do it
hey I got arrested and I got sent to a
program right you did six months there
actually I sent one program and I was
there for like a week I found out my
ex-wife blocked me on Instagram and so I
got high you stupid and then I went back
to court turn myself in they sent me to
another program where I did six months
and actually I go sports tennis to do
six months if I ended up doing seven
months and then I did another you know
continuous to that 18 months 17 months
sober you know I still be living and I
started managing was hoping living and
all that and had a sponsor and sponsee
youth but yeah I got uncomfortable and
stubborn a and a roundup back over you
does your family know where you're at
today
yeah where do they tell you they love me
Jimmy's honest as possible with them I'm
not gonna tell them like the details of
everything I'm doing cuz it's just gonna
be heartbreaking you know but think yeah
I mean generally in there what's up what
do you do for money now honestly it's a
little unreal
everything everyone does down here is
illegal a boost so you play music yeah I
just didn't I don't really play any more
professionally obviously the music helps
you deal with everything music is not
really an option it's it's it's just
it's music it's like a language it's
like if I'm gonna speak your thinker
know how I feel about something I
usually figure out how that is via music
I guess
yeah musics essential I said they're
nothing what do you think the chances
are of you getting clean and off the
street the chances I say they're high
super do you play I mean it may seem
like I'm just being like just wishful
thinking whatever but I enjoy being
sober a lot I really did it's just again
I would like to be sober now I was
talking to my buddy earlier all right
it's just the fear of detoxing news
pain in the ass it's not just being the
answer if you looking done what do they
give you when you detox
um subutex just a boxing just like a co2
you know lower taper down you know this
hope for a little bit but then it's it's
just I mean I'm gonna mustard I mean
Alice I know what I need to do I know
how to do it even I'm just postponing
the inevitable I guess yeah so do you
have kids
no no kids and I want to have kids
absolutely I don't want to miss out on
that at all at all
I love my niece and my nephew so much oh
say I'm 36
yeah but I'm glad I don't have kids now
cuz I would just that would just be
maybe a cure that
yeah well Rocco thank you so much for
talking with me and thank you and good
luck with wherever you go from here
thank you that's a little song
[Music]
you